قد يساعد الفواق الأطفال على تنظيم
تنفسهم في دراسة قادها
باحثون من كلية لندن الجامعية راقبوا 13
مولودًا جديدًا وجدوا أن الفواق أثار
موجة كبيرة من إشارات الدماغ التي
يمكن أن تساعد في نمو الطفل ،
اقترح باحث كبير في الدراسة
أن نشاط الدماغ قد يساعد الأطفال على
التعلم  كيفية مراقبة عضلات التنفس التي
تؤدي إلى القدرة على التحكم في
التنفس طواعية ، يُنظر إلى الفواق في
وقت مبكر يصل إلى تسعة أسابيع من الحمل
، والأطفال الذين يولدون ما لا يقل عن ثلاثة أسابيع
زوبعة مبكرة لمدة 15 دقيقة
كل يوم ، كان لدى الأطفال حديثي الولادة المشاركين في
الدراسة أقطاب كهربائية موضوعة على فروة رأسهم
و  أجهزة الاستشعار الموجودة على جذوعهم
لمراقبة الفواق ،
وجد الباحثون أن التقلصات في
أغشية الطفل تنتج ثلاثة
أوزان دماغية يعتقدون أن الموجة الدماغية الثالثة
تسمح للأطفال بربط صوت هيكس
للفواق بالانقباض الجسدي الذي
يشعرون به في لحظة الصحة اليوم أنا ماندي
جاثر